♪
>> Ben: OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
UNITES AMERICANS NOTHING
COMPARES TO SPORTS.
SPORTS ARE HOW WE MARK THE
CHANGING OF THE SEASONS.
SPORTS DRAW US TO THE SOUNDS OF
RUBBER ON THE COURT IN SPRING,
THE GREENEST FIELDS YOU HAVE
EVER SEEN IN THE SUMMER.
THE CRISP FALL DAYS OF CRISP
COLLEGE CHANTS COLD SNOW DAYS OF
WINTER WHERE YOU CAN'T FEEL YOUR
TOES BUT YOU WON'T SIT DOWN.
A CONNECTION TO THE PAST AND THE
FUTURE.
GENERATIONS OF FANS FROM ALL
BACKGROUND ALL WALKS OF LIFE WHO
FIND THEMSELVES TOGETHER TO
SHARE IN SORROW OR GLORY AS THE
DAY DECIDES.
SPORTS IS OUR GREAT TEACHER.
OFFERING US LESSONS THAT GUIDE
US FROM A YOUNG AGE FOR THE REST
OF OUR LIVES.
LESSONS ABOUT COURAGE AND GRIT,
THE IMPORTANCE OF TEAM WORK AND
DILIGENCE.
HOW TO PLAY LIKE A CHAMPION,
EVEN IN A LOSS.
SPORTS HAS BEEN AT THE CENTER OF
AMERICAN UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
RACE, IMMIGRATION, RELIGION, AND
MERITOCRACY.
THE BASEBALL PLAYOFFS BEGIN
TONIGHT AND FROM JACKIE ROBINSON
TO SANDY KOUFAX TO CLEMENTY,
CHILDREN LEARNED WHAT IT MEAN TO
BE A GOOD AMERICAN WATCH THESE
FIGURES GIVE THEIR ALL IN THE
FIELD OF PLAY.
SO WHY IS IT THAT SPORTS TODAY
SEEMS TO BE A PLACE OF DIVISION
NOT UNITY?
SOMETHING USED TO BREAK US
FURTHER APART NOT BRING US
TOGETHER?
WHEN DID COMPETITION BECOME SUCH
A BAD THING?
20 YEARS AGO AFTER 9/11 GETTING
BACK TO SPORTS WAS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT IT WASN'T JUST A SIGN
THAT AMERICA WAS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
IT WAS A SIGN THAT WE WERE
CONFIDENT AND UNAFRAID.
EIGHT YEARS AGO TEARS TURNED TO
CHEERS AND ROARS WHEN DAVID
ORTIZ TOLD THOSE COWARDLY
MARATHON TERRORISTS WHO CITY OF
BOSTON WAS.
THE SAME MOTIVATION EXISTS TODAY
AS WE WERE FIRST COMING BACK
FROM LOCKDOWNS WE ALL JOINED THE
CROWDS OF FANS WHOSE PROUD
VOICES CARRIED OUR NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
BUT THIS CREATES AN EXTREME
DIVISION BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE TOLD
AND WHAT WE SEE ON THE SCREEN.
YOU PROBABLY HEARD ON SUNDAY
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER WE CAN HAVE CHRISTMAS
GATHERINGS OR NOT.
WELL, HE DID THAT ON CBS.
BETWEEN THIS AND THIS.
AS MUCH AS MEDIA FEAR MONGERS
DECRY THESE COLLEGE AND
PRO-FOOTBALL GAMES AS SUPER
SPREADER EVENTS THE EVIDENCE
SHOWED THEY DON'T HAVE A LEG TO
STAND ON IN.
RECENT WEEKS, THE USE OF SPORTS
TO DIVIDE US HAS MOVED TO
INDIVIDUAL PLAYERS AND THEIR
PERM BELIEFS ABOUT VACCINATION.
NBA PLAYERS LIKE JONATHAN ISAAC
AND DRAYMOND GREEN MOUNTED
ELOQUENT DEFENSES ON THE RIGHT
TO MAKE THEIR OWN MEDICAL
DECISIONS MAKING IT CLEAR THAT,
YES, THEY HAVE TAUGHT THIS
THROUGH MUCH TO THE FRUSTRATION
OF THE OVERWHELMINGLY SPORTS
JOURNALISTS WHO WANT THEM TO GO
ALONG WITH THE NARRATIVE.
AND LET'S TALK ABOUT THOSE
JOURNALISTS.
PARTICULARLY ESPN.
THE WORLDWIDE LEADER HAS BEEN A
CONSTANT FORCE FOR DIVISION IN
RECENT YEARS.
DRIVING RACE AND GENDER FOCUSED
NARRATIVES, LAUDING ACTS OF
LEFTIST POLITICAL PROTESTS, AND
EVEN SIDELINING QUALIFIED
REPORTERS LIKE RACHEL NICHOLS IN
SERVICE OF THE WOKE AGENDA.
JUST TODAY THE EXCELLENT AND
TALENTED SAGE STEELE IS FACING
ENORMOUS BACKLASH FOR HER
COMMENTS ON RACE, VACCINE
MANDATES AND MORE.
FAILED FORMER ESPN HOST TURNED
COLIN KAEPERNICK BIO-PIC
PRODUCER JAMEL HILL CALLED HER A
CLOWN FOR EXPRESSING THOSE
VIEWS.
ESPN SAID THEY EMBRACE DIFFERENT
POINTS OF VIEW IN A STATEMENT.
BUT DO THEY REALLY?
THIS WOULD BE A GOOD TEST.
LET'S CONSIDER SOMEONE WHO ESPN
HAS HAD ON THEIR PROGRAMMING FOR
YEARS.
JOURNALISM PROFESSOR KEVIN
BLACKSTONE OF MARYLAND.
WHAT ARE SOME OF HIS VIEWS?
WELL HE HAS REPEATEDLY CALLED
FOR BOYCOTTING ISRAEL FROM ALL
SPORTS AND BANNING THEM FROM THE
OLYMPICS AS AR PAR TIED STATE.
IS HE HAS CALLED FOR PULLING THE
ALL STAR TEAM FROM ATLANTA AND
NINE FUTURE SPORTS EVENTS TO
GEORGIA OVER ELECTION LAW.
BANNED FLYOVERS AND PLAYING OF
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM WHICH HE
CALLS A WAR ANTHEM BEFORE GAMES.
EVEN COMPLAINED ABOUT BEING
FORCED TO SIT THROUGH IT THAT'S
A LEFTIST ACADEMIC ESPN THINKS
YOU NEED TO HEAR.
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM LIKE WHEN
SAGE STEELE SHARES HER OPINIONS.
SHE BROKE RULE NUMBER 1.
SHE TALKED AND SHE SAID
SOMETHING WOKE CORPORATE DIDN'T
AGREE WITH AMERICANS ARE TIRED
OF THIS WOKE CRAP.
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT'S FILLED
WITH THE UNDERLYING HYPOCRISY OF
KOWTOWING TO THE INTEREST OF
CHINA.
BY NOW YOU KNOW ALL ABOUT THAT
STORY.
HOW AN AMERICAN SPORTS LEAGUE
WITH A CORRUPT RELATIONSHIP WITH
SHOE MAKERS MADE IN HORRIBLE
OVERSEAS CONDITIONS HAD TO
ENGAGE IN ALL MANNER OF SONG AND
DANCE PRETENDING TO LOOK THE
OTHER WAY BECAUSE OF GM HAD THE
AUDACITY TO SEND ONE TWEET.
LEBRON JAMES HAS LOTS OF
OPINIONS BUT CHINA, WHAT DOES HE
KNOW ABOUT CHINA?
AS AUTHOR ETHAN STRAUS, LONG
TIME NBA REPORTER WRITES:  IT
COULD BE ARGUED THAT THE NBA FIX
STATES MORE ON CHINA AN ON
AMERICA EVEN IF THE VAST
MAJORITY OF TV MONEY COMES FROM
THE U.S. VIEWERSHIP.
THE LEAGUE FIELDS HIT A CEILING
IN HOME COUNTRY CHINA BECOMES
OBSESSION AS MASSIVE THEORETICAL
GROWTH ENGINE.
THIS ISN'T A QUESTION ABOUT
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO ASK DO
THEY HATE THEIR CUSTOMERS FOR
BEING AMERICAN?
IS WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON HERE
WISHFUL THINKING?
THE DESIRING TO DESCROFL THAT DR
ACTION SERIES WNBA OUTSELLS
MICHAEL JORDAN NEWLY TOXIC MASS
COULD YOU LITTLE BIT.
THE INSTITUTION OF SPORTS IS
BEING TURNED AGAINST THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO GO TO THE GAMES AND
BUY THE TICKETS AND CHEER.
IT IS DRIVEN BOTH BY GLOBALIST
CORPORATIONS WHO NO LONGER THINK
OF THEMSELVES AS INNATELY
AMERICAN AND BY A LEFTIST
DOMINATED MEDIA COMPLEX WHO
DESPISES THE FANS OF THE VERY
GAMES THEY COVER.
CLOSER TO HOME, PARENTS MUST
WORRY ABOUT THEIR DAUGHTERS
COMPETING AGAINST THEIR
NEIGHBORS' SONS BECAUSE OF
INTERSECTIONAL MADNESS
MASQUERADING.
EVEN PROUD LESBIAN ATHLETES
MARTINE INTO NATED LEAVE HAVE A
ALLOWING TRANSGIRLS TO COMPETE
AGAINST BIOLOGICAL GIRLS.
BUT DESPITE ALL OF THIS.
SPORTS FINDS A WAY.
THERE IS STILL THAT HUMAN DESIRE
FOR THE CONNECTION THAT BRINGS
US TOGETHER AS FANS DESPITE ALL
THE EFFORTS TO DIVIDE US.
MY MOM IS A DEDICATED BASEBALL
FAN.
HERE SHE IS WITH HER FRIEND
SCOOTER AND BOBBY.
FOR YEARS THEY SAT TOGETHER AND
SHARE STORIES AND GRIPES AND
CHEERED ON THE NATIONALS
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON.
THEY HAVE STRONG OPINIONS ABOUT
EVERYTHING IN D.C. SPORTS FOR
THE PAST 50 YEARS.
THERE IS NO REASON THAT PEOPLE
FROM SUCH DIFFERENT WALKS OF
LIFE SHOULD END UP AS FRIENDS
BUT THAT'S THE POWER OF SPORTS.
IT BRINGS US TOGETHER IN WAYS
THAT SURPRISE US.
IT GIVES US IDEALS TO STRIVE
FOR.
AND EACH IF THE LEFT HAS SOUGHT
TO CORRUPT SPORTS WITH THEIR
WOKE AGENDA, THEIR MISSION IS
ULTIMATELY DOOMED.
THEY VIEW SPORTS AS A TOOL TO
USE AGAINST THE PEOPLE.
WHETHER WE KNOW IT BINDS US
TOGETHER AS CITIZENS AND
FRIENDS.
DR. FAUCI CAN'T STAND IN FRONT
OF 100,0